I mean,
it'll be a while before anybody's
excited about anybody fighting Jon Jones.
Cause it's like, what do you got?
You know, you got a dude who's just,
there's certain guys like remember when
Anderson was in his prime and you're
like, what are you going to, who
are you going to throw at him?
There was nobody there to, Weidman came
along. Everybody that they threw at him,
you're like, hm, what's Anderson
going to do to this dude?
When's Annison got a knockout?
You should know Cami.
When's he going to connect on this guy?
And I think that we're in that
situation now with John. You know,
we've got a Tiago Santos fight that's
coming up. It should be interesting. Yeah.
But it's just the interesting thing
is that Santos is a murderous Stryker.
Is he going to be able to connect? That's
the, that's what makes an interesting.
I think Jones has some of the
best defense, the best wrestling,
grappling and striking
just doesn't get hit.
Distance side kick to your fucking
knee cap is no longer there.
And then when you fucking
thinking about that psychic boom,
left elbow to the eye. Orbital. Yup.
It's a tough puzzle. He's like, and he's,
he doesn't use, he's not light in his
fees, just right there in front of you,
like an unmovable force.
You know,
it's just going to stand
right there in front of you.
You're not going to go back or nothing.
It's just every catches you catching
a break. He tried to take a breath,
breath of air. What happened?
Wow. Wow. Wow. Pouring it on Ya.
So it's kicking your legs front,
kicking you in the body over and
over and he sees you slowing down.
He's a Predator, man. I wish. Like
they can make a science experiment.
Make mighty mouse tool five. I meant
that fight happen or shrink Jon Jones.
I make that fight happen. Yeah, no shit.
Right. No Shit. That would be crazy.
That would be crazy.
Yeah.
See the thing is no tool five or
can move like mighty mouse moves.
You would have to see how can mighty
mouse move it to a five? Yeah,
because the thing about gravity, there's
no gravity fucking with them. Yeah.
When he's won 25 he's fucking cutting
angles and he's woo woo. Where is he now?
He's on your legs is he
could do everything. But it's
technique though, is also,
that's when I see him doing
the things like kicks,
like a fucking tie dude shoots a double
leg, like a fucking good wrestling dude.
It's not like just an
athletic guy that's explosive.
Everything is done just right. You
know, same thing with John. You know,
he's got great technique everywhere.
Yeah.
I mean Matt Hume has produced some great
fighters, but then there's mighty mouse.
Like he's produced some great town,
but then this mighty mouse,
he's like Stan's way out. And you
gotta wonder like, is it mighty mouse?
Is it Matt Hume putting more emphasis
on him? Is it a combination of things?
Cause you usually,
when you get a guy that's that good,
you get a gym that starts producing
multiple champions like that.